j'écoute un problème Chelsea pour hier
soir j'aurais pas dû filer comme c'est
totalement nul de s'excuser allez
explique-moi tout de suite ce que tu as
sur le cœur voilà
ça fait qu'une journée que tu es là
était déjà intégrée et moi qui ai vécu
ici toute ma vie je me sens toujours
décalée je voudrais juste être Rubik's
Killman une ado normal oh mais c'est nul
ça
Ruby tu es une grande craquette tu crois
pas que tu devrais rêver un peu mieux
qu'être juste normal dans la vie
oh ma jolie ramolli mimi poupinette tu
sais de quoi tu as besoin de beaux
cheveux d'une nageur de sirène non mais
ce serait un plus ce qu'il te faut Ruby
Gilman c'est voir à quel point ta vie
pourrait être super je te conseille de
prendre un congé a
quatique ok
allons-y ouais
salut
c'est connard ouais c'est connard
salut salut
on se retrouve tout à l'heure pour que
tu m'aides avec les cours OK
en fait je préférais la toute première
version
[Musique]